something that I know is interesting to
you because it's been discussed
everywhere is this whole Adam 22 thing
and for the people listening to my
content you know there's there's a big
cuck culture for whoever doesn't know
what that means it's the idea of either
a guy or a girl you know getting off or
being interested in their significant
other sleeping with or doing something
sexual with someone else that they
aren't in a relationship with so there's
this very big content creator uh goes by
Adam 22 he has uh bunch of different
companies he does um oh my god dude I'm
even forgetting what his uh what the
hell is this his thing called well he's
got an only fans with his wife where he
brings on porn stars they interview them
and then they bang them afterwards for
the only F subcribers he's got a podcast
called no jumper the no jumper that's
what I was trying um yeah he's got a
bunch of different I guess assets in his
ecosystem but it's weird to me because
it seems like he did this whole cucking
thing as a stunt to get reach and money
because um I saw him in an interview on
some other podcast in the last week on a
clip somewhere and and he basically
admitted you know like the main reason
why we did it was because we knew that
it was going to get some some reach we
just didn't think it was going to get as
much reach as it got he was like it was
like 10 20 50 times more than what they
thought it would uh do and you know to
pimp out your wife the mother of your
child by the way like they have a kid
together like could you imagine being
this kid going into the public school
system and they find out that your dad
Adam 22 and your mom is Lena the Pug or
whatever the [__] her name is Lena the
Pug whatever it is the plug the Pug
whatever it is and it's like you know
your you know your parents pimp each
other out for like views on social media
and for clout it's like you know but
this is the place that we're at and we
see other creators do this as well like
I've seen some of these twitch streamers
now um what's that blue-haired guy's
name Destiny sneako admitted to going to
these cuck parties in the past before
although he seems to have uh pulled away
from uh um you know co-signing that
lifestyle he seems to have uh you know
uh put it down now or walked away from
it but you know the fact there's so many
people that publicly talk about sharing
their girlfriend or their wives with
other people and then the sickness that
they feel afterwards as a result of it
it's just like man dude like you reap
what you sow you know you play these
stupid games you're going to get stupid
rewards and people need to in my opinion
anyway they shouldn't celebrate this
[__] they should squash it you know they
shouldn't be signing up for this guy's
only fans they shouldn't be amplifying
these dorks that are that are like doing
these streams for hours you know in some
cases throwing them money and like these
people are losers you know can you can
you see the reality of crazy of of these
of these disgusting human beings and how
they choose to live their life and it's
like you want to celebrate it that's
fine dude you're part of that tribe
you're not part of my tribe I just draw
a perimeter around myself and you stay
over there it's simple Le 100% it's it's
it's lunacy to me what what I just don't
get is it was definitely a publicity
stun but the guy's got so much money
already why would he care to sell his
wife sell his dignity for he's got money
already he's making millions and
millions a year I don't know I mean
anything for attention for I mean like
who the hell knows you know there's
there's there's got to be some
underlying reason you know behind it
maybe it's like I've tried everything
you know to get more than 50 million
views a month and this got me 100
million views a month so hurah but you
know my wife had to get [__] down by
Tyrone here in this PornHub video go
check it out
now basically what it is it's Insanity
you could not pay me enough money to let
somebody sleep with me you couldn't pay
me enough money there you literally
could offer me a billion dollars cash
and I would tell you no and there are a
lot of guys that would say are you crazy
yes if that makes me crazy I am crazy my
dignity is worth more than the money
it's yeah it's it's called having some
stand standards and some dignity in your
life it's a great now I have a billion
dollars but I I feel like a worthless
piece of [__] it's not worth it to me
I'd rather not have the billion the
internet will never forget this right
stuff like this never never disappears
oh dude yeah oh the memes are gonna be
going on for years it's crazy but uh
listen teach their own if that's what he
if he wants to be stupid let him be
stupid maybe his angle was there is no
you know there is no bad news there's no
bad press uniform maybe that's what it
is who knows so stupid what other people
are trying to bring this logic into it
where saying oh well you know she was
sleeping with all these girls or or she
was letting him sleep with all it's very
different he is not bisexual she is she
enjoyed being with those women he does
not enjoy being with men it's a very
would say that that that men love to
complicate their life and justify why
they do it and that was some of the push
back that I got when I talked about that
on social media especially on on on
Twitter where guys that were coming at
me like shut up rich you don't know what
you're talking about this guy's banging
more girls than you are blah blah blah
you know they have three you know three
all the time so what it's like are you
[__] like what is wrong with you
that you think that it's okay for
another man to be banging your wife
right
like is this where we are in culture and
Society if fine you know if that's the
case fine again you stay on your side
this is my perimeter we ain't hanging
out bro I really hope you guys enjoyed
that clip if you want to watch the full
length podcast you can find that over
here that clip's from if you're new to
the channel make sure you hit subscribe
over here and pin down below in the top
comment you'll find a bunch of useful
links to my website my supplement line
books and a bunch of other stuff have an
amazing day peace out